die neunzehnte sache ist ich habe ein
paar freunde herzlich willkommen hier zu
einem neuen video auf einem kanal hab
mir gedacht weil es letzten beiden male
recht gut bei euch ankamen und ihr das
auch gewünscht hatte dass ich mal wieder
so 21 fakten über mich video mache habe
ich mir wieder über die letzten 12
wochen 20 dinge rausgesucht in meinem
alltag die ich irgendwie immer mache
oder rausgefunden haben über mich und
die wollte ich euch jetzt einfach mal
vorstellen und ich würde sagen der
ersten sache bin ich mir nicht mal
wirklich sicher ob ich das schon mal
gesagt habe und zwar mache ich immer
sprach das ist genau passen dass ich
gerade whatsapp nachricht bekommen weil
ich mache immer sprachnachrichten
whatsapp ich macht nahezu normale
nachrichten auch wenn es noch etwas ist
wie hey ya bin unterwegs oder helfern
dann kommst du immer eine
sprachnachricht weil ich finde dieses
tippen darauf so viel länger als einfach
zu sagen wo bleibst du zweite sache ich
bin nur produktiv ganz früh am morgen
und ganz spät am abend zwischendrin ich
kann nicht sagen hey ich komme von der
uni nach hause um 13 uhr und von 13 bis
18 uhr werde ich nur lernen und bla
das kriege ich nicht hin ich sitze dann
hier mach erst ein video top down runde
machen wir zu essen machen was mit
freunden und danach bin ich erst
produktiv beziehungsweise davor dritte
sachen über mich ich liebe extrem
spontane aktionen so was wie
beispielsweise hey wir sind nicht alle
so schön zusammen beim abendessen mit
paar kumpels lass doch mal einfach mit
dem zug nach amsterdam fahren oder lasst
doch mal einfach dies machen oder hey
wollen wir nicht einfach mal irgendwo
natürlich ist es einerseits cool wenn
dinge geplant werden und ich mag es auch
wenn dinge geplant werden wie
beispielsweise urlaub und so war man
dann natürlich auch viel planen muss das
programm et cetera angeht aber spontane
dinge ich weiß nicht es gibt so viele
coole sachen die einfach nur spontan
cool sind hoffe übrigens das passt mit
der kameraeinstellung und mit dem ton
ich hab da so ein bisschen versucht
nicht um zu gucken was ist noch so viel
besseres equipment gibt und
hey ich bin luca der vierte effekt über
mich ich hab schon drei mal meine apple
iphone 6 kopfhörer verloren also ich hab
das iphone 6 seit dem start also seit
oktober september oder so glaube ich das
ist jetzt ein bisschen mehr als ein
halbes jahr ich habe schon drei mal
einfach meine kopfhörer verloren ich
weiß ich hab sie kein mal wieder
gefunden ich habe immer wieder neu
gekauft man kosten 25 euro oder so das
geht eigentlich noch klar aber ich hab's
einfach dreimal verloren und ich weiß
ich nicht wo die sinn fünfte sache würde
ich am liebsten mal gerne zeigen aber
ich habe den glauben verloren und zwar
es gibt ja zwei arten von fepex einmal
diesen mit denen mit dem stift wo man so
eine flüssigkeit drauf macht und einmal
den wo man so ein system darüber zieht
ich nutze nur den mit dem mit dem ding
mit dem bald ich suche mal eben vier
freunde dieses ding das ist kein product
placement ich werde nicht dafür bezahlt
dass ich den irgendwie ihr euch zeige
oder so aber ich nutze immer nur den es
gibt ja einmal den der irgendwie somit
mit drüber mitte ich ja ich bin jetzt
den elefanten tipp-ex hier die sechste
sache ist wieder aufs iphone bezogen und
zwar mache ich anstatt also es gibt ja
diese notizen app beim iphone und
wahrscheinlich auch flächen in welchen
android-handys oder so und dann statt
dass ich ganz ganz viele kleine notizen
mache einfach wie beispielsweise hey du
musst noch milch einkaufen und das
einkaufen und dann in einer notiz
du musst noch die hausaufgaben machen
und dann noch mal eine andere notiz muss
doch auf die und die mail eingehen habe
ich einfach eine ganz lange notiz ich
würde jetzt gerne zeigen aber durch die
private sachen drin
also ich hab einfach quasi eine notiz
was ich hätte fast schon einer notiz was
los bei dir schreibt sie gar nichts auf
im leben und dann wenn man die durchgeht
kann man dann erstmal so 15.000
milliarden jahre scrollen
sie besagt dass recht simpel und zwar
ich liebe veränderungen ich bin ein typ
der nicht sagt hey wenn du bock auf das
hat dann macht das nicht da sondern
macht lieber etwas komplett neues so
anstatt dass man was altes verändert
würde ich immer irgend etwas neues
machen
also ich weiß dass es in der
kommunikations theo fast weiß zumindest
dass es beim kaufverhalten immer gesagt
wird es ist schwieriger und wichtiger
kunden bei einem unternehmen zu halten
anstatt neue kunden zu gewinnen aber ich
finde es besser wenn man immer versucht
irgendwas neu das ist während total
bürger vergleich hoffe ihr wisst was ich
meine also ich mag es einfach wenn
jemand sagt ja ich möchte meinen kanal
umstrukturieren bei auf youtube jetzt
beispielsweise bezogen oder ich möchte
irgendwie was neues machen oder so achte
sache ganz simpel ich will nie im leben
bungee jumpen ich habe richtig bock auf
sowas wie tiefseetauchen oder aus dem
flugzeug springen mit einem fallschirm
oder paragliding oder was weiß ich aber
alles bis auf bungee jumping bungee
jumping ist etwas muss ich echt sagen
habe ich mehr respekt vor weil kann mir
das ob ich glaube das ist nicht mehr
cool also natürlich für den moment wenn
du darunter springst hast du voll den
adrenalin kick und so einfach aber ich
weiß nicht das bringt doch irgendwie
also ich bin einfach kein fan vom bungee
jumping obwohl ich noch nie gemacht
haben nicht mehr zu nehmen
die neunte sache ich hatte schon 444 ich
glaube 450 glaubt vier mal hatte ich
schon herzrasen wegen youtube und uni
stress unserem ganzen schild also dass
du denkst dein herz explodiert quasi
ganz wird richtig heiß und du denkst
einfach ja auch was los
also das hatte ich schon viermal weil
ich da irgendwie bis in die nacht noch
versucht habe in wien video zu machen
und gelernt habe und alles mögliche aber
derzeit sind die person vorbei ich habe
heute die letzte klausur geschrieben und
hoffe dass ich habe so auch tabletten
bekommen herzrasen vom kardiologen das
auch sehr stark zehnten viele meiner
youtube und schule oder youtube und uni
zusammen das geht nicht und alles also
ich hab auch wirklich versucht nur das
nötigste zu lernen aber trotzdem an die
ersten klausuren die ich geschrieben
habe 17 17 und 23 glaube ich also 2 plus
2 plus bei - und das geht eigentlich
sogar klar finde ich also natürlich
jetzt kommen aber für mich ist es
eigentlich schon recht gut dafür dass
ich nicht ich weiß dass ich dafür
nicht nur das nötigste gelernt habe und
dass das wirklich so was ich und was
weiterhelfen ich hasse mittlerweile den
legria waldwinkel also ich habe derzeit
einfach so fucking viele kameras bei mir
rum liegen und sogar profi steht noch
klar weil die gopro wenigstens noch eine
gute konturen und und farbtiefe hat und
alles mögliche aber die legria hat
einfach schlechte farben die ich da hast
du den weitwinkel irgendwie mittlerweile
weil ich mag weitwinkel liegen wir nicht
mehr also natürlich der ton von der
legria da hat glaube ich keine andere
kompaktkamera was besseres zu bieten
aber ich weiß nicht ich finde die legria
einfach nicht mehr cool also ich hasse
mittlerweile diesen diesen legria weit
wird es wolken es mal ganz schlicht ich
liebe chris osgood die christen sind
meine lieblings kellogg's 13 ich kriege
immer noch gänsehaut bei einem flugzeug
staat allerdings nur beim start nicht
wenn wir in der luft sind oder wenn
turbulenzen sind oder wenn wir landen
oder keine ahnung was nur beim start
wenn man gerade so wenn man gerade so
ist von dieser position bis in diese
position da habe ich durchgehend
gänsehaut und angst ich weiß nicht warum
aber da kommen dann manchmal luftlöchern
alles und blau und ich flieg in letzter
zeit echt schon häufiger also für meine
verhältnisse ich bin jetzt in dem
letzten monat glaube ich schon sechs mal
geflogen oder so das ist für mich viel
aber ich bekomme irgendwie immer beim
flug start richtig gänsehaut und ansteck
nummer 14 ich schaue prison break schon
seit glaube ich anderthalb jahren und
bin erst in mitte staffel 2 weil ich
dann immer eine folge schaue und dann
ist ein mega cliffhanger aber dann muss
ich pennen gehn oder dann warte ich
wieder eine woche weil dann irgendwie
mal nett fix nicht funktioniert hat und
dann wieder so also ich schau die serie
quasi schon seit anderthalb jahren und
hat eigentlich erst 20 wollten davon
geschafft 15 ich versuche alles zu
planen also ich habe überall
irgendwelche so zettelchen da steht
jetzt was auf rückseite das sind die
geplanten videos und ich habe hier vorne
halt auch noch solisten also hier sind
beispielsweise überall noch solisten mit
ganz ganz vielen dingen die ich einfach
noch machen möchte die ich wo ich mir
gesagt hab ja auch ich mache mal ein
neues profilbild oder ich muss noch hier
ein paket abholen und ich muss noch das
paket für dings rausschicken
und ich muss noch bei meiner mutter die
hecke machen und was weiß ich alles also
ich schreibe immer alles auf und
versuche mein komplettes leben zu planen
aber es klappt einfach nicht gesteht
dann hier und es steht dann seit zwei
wochen auf dem zettel dann sage ich mir
kommt kann es auch sein lassen
eigentlich weil ich dann eh keine zeit
dafür finden oder
also ich versuche mein leben zu planen
aber es gelingt mir irgendwie nicht 16
ich habe derzeit wieder einen relativ
normalen schlafrhythmus das heißt für
mich normal ist das nicht so abends
gegen 11 12 uhr müde werde das liegt es
daran dass ich abends eigentlich immer
noch ins fitnessstudio gehe und dann bin
ich auch wirklich morgens also ich habe
mir jetzt heute mag ein bäcker gestellt
bin ich eigentlich schon so gegen 9 uhr
glaube ich aufgewacht also für mich ist
es normal wenn man wenn man bei mir dass
er damals so ich bin es um 3 uhr müde
geworden wenn ich mir keinen wecker
gestellt hat kann ich bis fünf uhr
nachmittags schlafen aber mittlerweile
durch die union alles möglich habe ich
wieder so eine vernünftige
lebensrhythmus und mein schlaf rhythmus
hat sich auch wieder normalisiert sache
nummer 17 ich habe derzeit sieben
kameras bei mir und dazu sind nicht
zugezählt meine webcam da von denen noch
drei habe mein iphone kamera meine ipad
kamera meinem macbook kamera also das
ist alles nicht dazu gezählt
ich habe sieben kompaktkameras also was
wie beispielsweise die canon legria -
oder die sony dsc x103 oder die
achtzehnte sache ich für klausuren fange
ich immer sehr sehr früh an zu lernen
also ich nehme es mir wirklich vor und
ich mach's in letzter zeit auch ich habe
es damals in der schule nicht gemacht
weil es langweilig war aber mittlerweile
im studium kannst du dir aussuchen was
du machen möchtest und so deswegen macht
es mir spaß und da fange ich auch
relativ frühzeitig an zwar immer nur so
ich fange dann so an und dann vor der
klausur ist es dann so aber ich fange
wenigstens schon mal langsam an und das
ist schon mal ein schritt bei mir in die
richtige richtung 19 sache ist ich habe
eine ukulele hier aber ich kann nicht
wirklich spielen ich hatte keine ahnung
dass hätten wir wahrscheinlich von dem
anfang von mein videos das einzige was
ich sowieso ein bisschen kann ist kann
ich auch nicht ja keine ahnung ich habe
damals mal bei unserem netzwerk gesehen
und dass die gehalt lag und dann habe
ich mir gedacht ich kaufe mir auch eine
und ja ihr braucht man da nicht zu sagen
hätten eine gekauft mir habe ich damit
bisher noch nicht gemacht
die letzte sache ich hatte damals in der
schule spanisch für ein ganzes jahr und
ich hab auch irgendwie die klausuren
alle 2 geschrieben oder drei das weiß
ich auch nicht wie ich das hingekriegt
aber das einzige was sich behalten hat
jetzt neben roller total.com aus unserem
kreis ist wirklich hero die potters das
heißt glaube ich irgendwie [ __ ]
oder so
das war's mit diesem 20 facts about me
video das heißt ich kann mir diese notiz
auf jeden fall schonmal werkstoffen ich
würde mich freuen wenn es euch gefallen
hat dass ihr die video eine bewertung
gibt oder meinen channels ab